like that made everything possible yeah
well that is the real the only saving
grace of the concept of white privilege
is that we do have to recognize that
some people got a really good deal and
some people got a really terrible deal
but the only reason why white privilege
is even something to consider is that
racism is real what white privilege is
not if the world was Barry Weiss or
there's all kinds of privilege right
like but what I was gonna say is if the
world was people like you or people like
Jamie we would never have to worry about
racism because it wouldn't even be a
consideration Jamie's on black Twitter
every day what are you doing over there
being a producer working but you know
I'm saying like if it was no racism that
concept would be totally irrelevant and
what we would be concentrating on is you
know who's making the best buildings
who's making the best music what whether
the contributions to culture we wouldn't
care about if they were coming from
Asian people or West Indian people we
wouldn't care but I think the
contribution of the left to make people
recognize I don't know privilege of all
kinds that's useful it's actually useful
to think about that what is not useful
is to say because you were X Y or Z
thing therefore you're out yes therefore
you have no stake and therefore in fact
you have sort of less of a claim on
truth and morality I'm sure that of what
happened recently with the woman from
CNN who was on patreon radio she accused
an african-american gentleman who she
didn't do my research she instead of
arguing the idea or discussing these
ideas and she said because of your white
privilege it's blinding you and he was
like explain he he gave her rope to you
know to me like as a person does jujitsu
he like gave her room he gave her room
and she went right into the choke she
has sank the choke in herself she
explained it even further he said I hate
to break it to you but I'm black and she
must have just felt her whole life all
of her intellectual credibility just go
[ __ ] wash flush down the toilet like
oh my god you just got exposed and this
is what
people love about preposterous thinking
preposterous thinking if it's given
enough time it's eventually gonna slam
into a wall and that's what we saw we
saw a truck with a [ __ ] brick on the
accelerator just slam right into the
wall because she thought she had a path
that you couldn't stop and this is the
path it's like if you're playing chess
but you have one super-powerful move
that it works it's not like a rook or a
queen no it has no rules it's just king
I just that's what she did basically she
had this super-powerful thing and it
didn't work it didn't work because this
guy was a part of the very protected
class that she was part of and she just
that way of thinking of just like
shortcuts to dismissing people but no
one else could pull that off except a
black man or a black woman if because of
who he is
he had the checkmate he's like ha ha and
the whole world went ha ha ha because
we've all seen that but it you can't say
anything if I if I was having this
discussion with her and she said because
of your white privilege I'd have to say
look okay you know let's go through the
thing let's unpack that I [ __ ] hate
that word unpack I hate it cuz it's
always brought it's always brought out
by people who really aren't unpacking
[ __ ] they're just explaining to you how
their ideology Trump's your ideology and
it's almost always like this
preposterous way of describing things
let me unpack that for you oh [ __ ] you
lady didn't have to he didn't have to
say that he said I'm black that was the
ultimate unpacking boom whether he's
right or she's right it's like that
those words white privilege oh that's
that it creates so many [ __ ]
headaches it does but you think it's
real though yes yeah it is sure it's
real because it's racist don't target me
the way they would target a black person
that's a hundred percent real it is real
it just gets used in this sloppy way and
it gets used to dismiss people yeah and
I don't think that's useful and the real
problem is not white privilege the real
problem is racists actual racists that's
the real problem and if there was no
racist that white privilege wouldn't be
a thing it's only a thing because of
racists and it's only a thing with
racists without racist
doesn't exist the problem with
african-americans or Asians or it.well
Asians is the real like this is a weird
one right like the Harvard thing where
agents are denied entry into Harvard
with the same standards that white
people like it because of rejas they and
they figured racism because they're good
because they study so hard and they do
get but if you look at that lawsuit in
the language that the school used to
sort of describe them as like antisocial
and robotic and all of these stereotypes
so awful it's crazy it's so crazy
it should read Wesley yang on this he's
a really interesting writer about this
um we're Wesley yang you should have him
on I wouldn't wrote a book a book of
essays called I think it's actually
called the souls of yellow folk this
year I'll connect it in um are you see
just interesting on this I used to teach
Taekwondo for a living yeah it was
around a lot of Korean people and one
when you know I learned Taekwondo from a
Korean man when I learned and I was
around so many Korean people I was
stunned by the the work ethic that
exists in these these families and the
the humbleness and the the this that the
way it was almost expected that you
never brag and that you work harder than
anybody and I had a friend who was he
was on the u.s. Taekwondo team to to
compete in the Olympic Games he was
working on a school work he was going
through his residency so he's probably
working on school work 10 to 12 hours a
day in between classes he would put his
bookbag on he would fill his book bag up
with with books and run the stairs at
the University up and down and then he
would come to the gym at night and train
and then he would travel to compete with
the world team and all that will call to
me while he was in college he was it was
medical school I mean I know he had bags
under his eyes you could stuff Christmas
trees it was [ __ ] insane this guy was
always tired but the work ethic that he
had was just I didn't have 1/10 of that
work that work ethic it was it was
impossible to ignore and he was so
spread then
and so tired all the time but he kept
working and he would talk about his
culture and he would talk about his
family and what it was dad expected of
him like he's like man in my house like
that you just [ __ ] did it like you
don't you just not there's not like oh I
feel tired today [ __ ] you get up go to
work and but that attitude has allowed
so many Asian people that discipline and
and and just this this culture of
performance and of achievement where
it's so it's so cherished that has
allowed so many Asian people to excel in
academia and the fact that Harvard
somehow or another steps in and says
we're going to we're gonna make it more
difficult for you because you work so
hard that is so crazy and so weird it's
so weird that they as this I mean if you
think about if you think about
institutions of higher learning Harvard
is the first one you think about it's
number one it's number one I call we
graduated from Harvard Oh done done
right Harvard h-bomb yeah and to have
them so blinded its it to me is that
they will be racist against the best
performance because they're performing
too well there's a disproportionate
number of them in the university so
gonna make it harder we're gonna raise
your standards yeah